i'm starting off with a little bit of a
selfish question here because olivia i
was reading
about your tattoos and i might be on the
hunt for a new one so can you tell our
viewers about the two super cool horror
movie tattoos you have and then if you
had to get another one
what would it be here i have one that's
um that i have actually with mccabe who
stars in 1978
and we really bonded over our love of
the movie american psycho
and so a couple months ago we got
american psycho matching tattoos and
mine says bone and his says
meat from when he's filling out the
crossword puzzle
um and we were like this is funny this
is how we became friends
oh we've got sweet matching american
psycho tattoos
and then i've got a 237 tattoo on my
like below my ankle that i gave myself
via stick and poke um for the shining
because that's the hotel room and that's
one of my favorite movies so
i have a little self-done shining tattoo
and then if i had to get another one
horror related
i don't know maybe i'd get a texas
chainsaw one because that in my opinion
is a perfect movie
and also i'm from texas and have been to
those
filming locations before so yeah like
the gas station and stuff oh my goodness
oh yeah you bet i've been you've got
hard time out of my life to go do that i
don't even know i'm shocked
as an especially big horror fan was
there any specific horror movie that
isn't overtly
referenced in these three films that you
still found yourself channeling when
playing either
sam or hannah oh i feel like a movie
that i
watched a few times for um
an element of of the the first and
second movie was
possession from 1981 and um
yeah that's a movie that i've kind of
referenced for myself and my own
performance as sam
and that like lee and i the director
talked about um a lot
in making some choices for things that
come about later in the
in the series but yeah we're running
this after 1994 is available so you are
safe you are saying
okay so the end of 1994 um
i watched possession as you can tell
from the title
for you know my my performance of being
possessed
sam yes which is pretty fun all right
after what i just said keon i'm gonna
like tiptoe into
1666 spoilers but i don't want to go
there but i do have to ask you about
making the transition from 94 to that
phone because it's not every day that
you know you get to see someone play two
main characters in two
different films that are connected and
filming back to back so given that
production process
what is one pro that you think enhanced
your work because of the way they were
shot and then
what's i guess a con or a challenge that
you had to overcome
both characters that i played are very
strong they have an inner strength and
an inner fight in them
so i feel like filming 1994
and really getting to dive into how much
dina cares and that how strong she
really is
and then leading into 1666 it was just a
perfect way to
lead into my 1666 character
knowing that i have that strength in me
as well as kiana and i can bring it to
this character as well
the challenge is was definitely the fact
that i'm human
and i was tired sometimes you know
sometimes i was like
i would get back to the hotel after
rapping and i was like
wow i really thought that i could just
like go through this and feel
completely energized the whole time but
there were definitely some days where i
was like
i feel like i want to sleep for 20 hours
because the roles were very demanding
physically emotionally
spiritually you know so in so many ways
so that was definitely a challenge
can 100 understand that so benji i was
reading about how you were kind of the
one who cracked the code with a key
shot at the very end of 1994 you figured
out the blocking so it made me wonder
do you have any interest in getting
behind the camera yourself
uh eventually eventually somewhere down
the line i feel like i still got to
build that muscle
uh but eventually for sure i know i got
the eye for it
when the time comes is there anything
that you saw lee do
on these films that you are going to
back pocket and apply on your own stuff
um i love the way
there's definitely a camera angle but
like more than that it's just the way
that she
directs like i love the fact that lee
doesn't move on until she's completely
satisfied
because that's the only way you can make
something good you can't just
you know oh i think it's all right let's
just move on for the sake of time like
screw
the sake of time right now if we're
making something at the best level we
can
like so that's what i really uh enjoy
and i took uh from lee that i will back
pocket for sure
all right olivia kiana i have one coming
at both of you right now so whoever
wants to jump in first feel free but
i love asking about the value of a scene
partner and i know you
two are exceptionally talented all on
your own but there's something about
working opposite someone else
that can bring something out of you that
maybe you couldn't bring out of yourself
so
what is one thing that the other did on
the set of either film that
you know made all the difference for you
and you wish you saw more out there
i think just the amount that we talked
like the days
um that we had to do like like the
monologue in the chemistry room or the
or the the overdose scene at the hot or
at the
grocery store like there was so much
communication between us
on those days where it was like
literally like what do you need right
now
like the cameras on you like what do you
need for me and vice versa
and i just feel like we talked so much
about those things and then like as it
went on like it got so much easier
to talk about those things as the
filming went on and then it just became
like second nature to like be
really really communicate in those times
i feel like what was special about
working with olivia
was um how you
really held space for me i feel you know
a lot of times when you're in a scene
with someone and it's not their coverage
and vice versa you kind of you don't you
don't give it
100 or you're not really as
present in the scene with them but i
feel like we both
held so much space for each other so
that we could we were really listening
to each other we were really attentive
to each other's needs and i really think
that
that was the same for our characters as
well you know our characters cared so
much about
what each other needed and that was
something that i feel like you gave me
as an
as an actor and i really appreciated
that yeah like it was great working with
you
that was really good i feel it when i
watch the movie i'm just gonna say this
because i don't think i'm allowed to say
anything about the second two but 94 is
officially one of my favorite movies of
2021.
you guys are so good in it and it just
speaks to my horror sensibilities so
much so
huge congratulations and thank you for
this delightful 90 slasher movie